hi so I don't know how many of you have
ever bought cupcakes for your favorite
website well today I am going to do that
just got my cupcakes with Twitter and
I'm gonna go visit them and give them
the treats that one for myself so I'm
here Twitter they just made new friends
w on Twitter hey I handled it my
cupcakes we Twitter check out their
amazing office
how long have you guys been this office
july this is the best little faster bird
each bird is different on each door and
it represents the name of the college
magpies w you want to tell out my new
twitter fans thanks for following
Justine and using Twitter we're here to
keep the tweets blow